all right here we go this is the only
Bay Teresa Garcia can get around to feed
her animals and retrieve any of her
belongings
a river burst its banks and flooded this
rural town in central California on
Thursday
people here say the fast-moving flood
water destroyed everything in its path
within minutes we're shocked that all
this happened as quick as it did so now
we're all you know we don't know what
we're gonna do because it's evidently
we're not going to be able to come back
here and live anymore so we're gonna
have to just take our losses in Southern
California some in the coastal city of
San Clemente were forced to leave their
Apartments as the Earth slid away from
their backyards
at least 35 out of 58 counties are on a
presidential emergency declaration for
areas hard hit by natural disasters I
think everyone should understand we had
a dynamic situation here we have another
rainstorm coming
the ground is continuing to move so
these structures are still in Peril and
from a city's perspective again safety
first so we're going to make sure that
that everything's set before we get to
go ahead for close to come back in the
United States West Coast is facing an
unusually wet season after two decades
of drought
its endangered lives destroyed homes and
turned roads into rivers
there have been power outages too and
with rain in the forecast there's likely
to be more flooding in the next few days